i'm here with jesse rowe who's a math
teacher at summit san jose and a khan
academy teaching fellow and and you had
some interesting ideas or questions
yeah one question that students ask a
lot when they start algebra is
why do we need letters why can't we just
use numbers for everything why letters
so like why do we have all these x's and
y's and z's and abc's when we start
dealing with with algebra yeah exactly
that's interesting why don't we let
people think about that for a second
so sal how would you answer this
question why do we need letters in
algebra so why letters so
there's a couple of ways i'd think about
it one is is if you have a an unknown so
if i were to write
x
plus 3
is equal to is equal to 10. the reason
why we're doing this is we don't know
what x is it's it's literally an unknown
and so we're going to try to solve for
it in some way but it did not have to be
the letter x we could have literally
written blank plus 3 is equal to 10. or
we could have written question mark plus
3 is equal to 10. so it didn't have to
be letters but we needed some type of
symbol it literally could have been
smiley face smiley face plus 3 is equal
to 10. but until you know it you needed
some type of a symbol to to represent
whatever that number is now we can go
and solve this equation and then know
what that symbol represents but if we
knew it ahead of time it wouldn't be an
unknown it wouldn't be a it wouldn't be
something that we didn't know so that's
one reason why i would use uh letters uh
and where just numbers by itself
wouldn't be helpful the other is when
you're describing relationships between
numbers so i could do something like um
i could say that whenever you give me
you if you give me a 3 i'm going to give
you a 4. and i could say if you give me
a five
i'm going to give you a six and i could
keep going on and on forever if you give
me a if you give me a 7.1 i'm gonna give
you an 8.1 and we could give i could
keep listing this on and on and on
forever maybe you could give me any
number and i could tell you what what
i'm going to give you but it would
obviously i'd run out of space and time
if i were to list all of them and we
could do that much more i guess
elegantly if we if we used letters if we
describe the relationship maybe what you
give me we call x and what i give you i
we call y and so i'll say look whatever
you give me i'm going to add one to it
and that's what i'm going to give back
to you and so now this very simple
equation here can describe an infinite
number of of relationships between x or
an infinite number of corresponding y's
and x's so now someone knows hey
whatever whatever x you give me you give
me 3 i add 1 to it and i'm going to give
you 4. you give me 7.1 i'm going to add
1 to it and give you 8.1 and so there's
there's no more elegant way that you
could have done it than using symbols
with that said i didn't have to use x's
and y's this is just a convention that
kind of comes to us from history i could
have defined what you give me as star
and what i give you as i don't know as
as smiley face and this also would have
been a valid way to express this so the
letters are really just symbols
nothing more